demande moins de moins d'impôts moins de
charges c'est qu'à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
on est submergé par les charges on n'en
peut plus on vit plus alors aujourd'hui
on travaille moi je travaille 40 heures
par semaine je vais plus aujourd'hui je
survis on soutient le mouvement sont
tous concernés et même les jeunes
je me considère en tant que telle n'a
peur pour notre avis son problème à
maquereau aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
son peuple qui est dans la rue c'est le
peuple c'est pas une entreprise c'est
pas des syndicats c'est le peuple de
france qui est là et ça ici attendait
pas et ça c'est très grave
et s'il ne fait rien ça va aller
beaucoup plus loin
[Musique]
il est en pleine tête
une gamine de chez pac halage à peine 20
ans elle a pris en pleine tête le
défigurer c'est cet inconscient ce
qu'ils font là alors il ya une
arrestation qui se passe ici c'est vous
la les mouvements des soupers de reculer
reculé entre eux du clip moi j'ai donc
voilà encore un peu encore un peu
messieurs encore encore et je vais vous
demander de rester ici toi dépasser le
passage piéton versée merci à casseurs
qui sont attaqués à 7
on voit là bas c'est une banque la
société générale
donc les gens qui essaient de casser des
vitrines de la société générale il ya
tout à coup tout de suite beaucoup de
beaucoup de gilet jaune qui se sont mis
à huer
ils ne veulent pas ce genre de violence
qui ne veulent pas qu'on ternissent leur
image donc des ensembles ya eu et et ont
forcé un peu les casseurs à se déplacer